everyone this is Steve with collider and
we are here at our studio at Sundance uh
I really want to give a huge thank you
like it really is difficult to cover
Sundance it's very expensive and I want
to give a huge thank you to our sponsor
filo for uh helping us Champion uh
independent cinema and allowing us to be
here at Sundance um and I really want to
say uh a little shout out to them but
filo is shattering shattering barriers
by placing the power to Greenlight films
in the hands of creators and fans and
you can learn a lot more about them by
visiting the site film. sweet I'm
interested I'm like let's do this yeah
listen uh and I really mean it though
like and you guys know like uh uh they
don't talk about how difficult and
expensive it is to be here you know what
I mean like is like a crowdsourcing app
or something uh it's no it's a whole
okay we talk about later it's a whole
thing check the yeah exactly everyone go
to the website and I'm actually being
very sincere I really say thank you to
them so um I have a million questions
for you guys but obviously I have to
start with you um and I hate doing this
but no one uh watching this will
probably have seen the movie yet so how
have you been describing it to friends
and family um that's been a that's been
a challenge for sure my mom keeps
getting mad at me she's like I need you
to give me something to say like I when
my friends asked me I don't know what to
say I I've been telling people it's a
movie about uh perspective and that
you're sort of getting to go on a
journey with um a couple different
characters
uh in Los Angeles and seeing sort of the
different sides of the city um through
them and their different perspectives so
you have directed oh Welcome to our
party Gabby Hoffman joining us on the in
the rear just walking by yeah you know
and we this is what we do at Sundance we
just have people joining the party there
we go um so you've directed obviously a
lot of music videos and this is your
first feature and and I'm just curious
how much did you debate like what do I
want my first feature to be like did
that go in your head at all about you
know what I mean or were you sort of
like this is the idea that is
germinating and this is the one I want
to do I think this has been the one for
a while I mean I've been working on the
version of this movie for over six years
so you know there wasn't always a time
when I thought it would be my first
movie for logistical reasons or you know
um just kind of we it took us a long
time to sort of get everything right and
it is sort of a swing of a concept and
and I didn't want to
uh try to take it on prematurely but um
I yeah it's it's definitely has a lot of
me and my life experience and my
co-writer Donnie in in in it and it
feels very personal even if it hopefully
is universal in a way so I like throwing
a curveball at the beginning of
interviews and this is for all of you
guys if someone has never seen anything
you've directed or anything you've acted
in what is the first thing you'd like
them watching and
why
nothing this
interview because why not I mean if you
haven't seen anything like then enter
anywhere I mean it's so extract I mean
it doesn't really matter I mean and
storytelling is so transformative you
know I feel like the the shelf life of a
film is what I'm so attracted to like
the films that I'm it influenced even
now or ones that were made 50 years ago
or you know when I was a teenager they
were the ones that were not directed or
made to for me it was the ones that I
discovered on you know happen dance so I
I love the discovery of FM and that the
audio have no idea you know we don't
know whether this film will be seen by
Our Generation or in 20 years generation
to come I I I love that about with El B
you know so it's so sweet sure but I I
think it's also a way of me getting you
to talk about a previous performance or
like a or one of those where it's like I
really like this
one lucky for me it doesn't
exists so this is my first movie the
short film but I don't know if you could
we'll see whatever ever focus on this
one future film lucky enough I was um
able to be a part of it Jack's my cousin
we grew up doing a lot of fun creative
things together and to see culminate in
this is super super special and he's a
superstar I'm super did you give him
five bucks to say that or is it 10 he's
not even my cousin
man hopefully a little more than F right
is there anything you want know Ah
that's a mean question I'll say the last
time I was at Sundance I came with a
movie called crystal fairy and I had
seen it in the director's living room
Sebastian Silva who I love very very
much and we made the film it was improv
we made it in 12 days in Chile and I
watched it in his living room and walked
home and I remember my husband and I
being like okay well too bad you know
and then I came to Sundance and watched
the very same cut a few weeks later and
I absolutely loved the movie I think
think it's a fantastic movie and I'm
bringing it up not because I think my
performance is all that interesting or
whatever but because then we came here
and we got to watch the movie in a room
with hundreds and hundreds if not
thousands of people I don't know I'm bad
with that stuff and it it it is why
being at film festivals is so exciting
and Powerful because movie making is
both a very personal experience and
movie watching and a communal one so the
personal of course is universal and so
to come together in a theater and you
get to experience it not just through
your own lens but through the shared
lens of The Human Experience and
sometimes you need that to reveal your
own feelings so I I'll that will be my
choice since it was my last time here
sure you've directed a number of cool
videos is there one particular that
you'd love people to watch if they've
never seen any I don't know I feel like
I love so many I don't think I could
pick one I feel like it's I think
because they're tied to music that I
love so much and I feel like to me music
is like one of the hardest things to
kind of rank and quantify I feel like I
don't know I love I love uh a lot of the
musicians I've gone to work with and
videos I've worked on but I don't think
I would pick one so I I I apologize but
I love talking about the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
so talk a little bit about with with
this film when you got in the editing
room what were some of the things that
like maybe surprised you that you didn't
expect or some of the obstacles you
needed to overcome I mean I think the
main obstacle to overcome is you watch
the First Assembly cut of your movie and
you think I will never work again in
this town and um I think the big
Obstacle of sort of being able to get
over that and understand that there is
that thing that you wanted to do is
inside of there and you just need to
sort of put in the elbow grease um I
mean coming from doing more short form
that was a big learning curve for me and
and the editing team you know um Jake
and and Tyler and everyone else involved
you know it was uh I'm used to basically
if I watch a cut and I don't like it if
it's a three-minute edit you can pull
two all nighters and completely re-edit
it if you want you know and with this
you're like pulling five all nighters
and one scene gets like a little better
and it's sort of so daunting and so kind
of hard to affect actual over you know
large change on on the the thing that
you're working on that you don't
actually see it you know you're doing
you're doing all this elbow grease and
this work you know for months and then
suddenly you do see the change but it's
so much more gradual because it's such a
longer you know bigger living organism I
haven't seen the movie yet but I did
read the Press notes and read as much as
I could and one of the things is you
talk about how there's like essentially
two parts to this film the first half
Works a certain way and the second half
is a little different so can you sort of
talk about uh why you want wanted to do
that and like that tonal shift if you
will I think just in general I mean the
movie is just taking turns as much as it
can you know even within sort of the
larger shifts that it's doing I think
it's kind of trying
to Swerve in between different genres
you know it'll be in one scene it's sort
of this kind of like tripped out really
subjective crazy you know uh inner
monologue of somebody and then within
that same story you're popping out into
like this super raw real uh relationship
moment you know um in that person's life
and so even within that I think I don't
know I think it's my first movie I just
wanted to try to throw as much you know
at the wall as I could and and and
feel like I was you know kind of saying
as much as I could at once and I feel
like all of it hopefully is in dialogue
with each other you know um I I hope it
doesn't you know um feel like a
scattered thing and I think that I'm
proud of the moments where where it
doesn't and it all kind of congeals but
uh that's sort of you know I feel like I
have a bunch of
different passions you know I have a
passion for this really technical kind
of surreal music video type of film
making and I have another passion that's
the super grounded kind of very um actor
character focused work on the craft and
I feel like trying to kind of always
bring them together in this project you
really did it's exciting it's exciting
to watch as audience M and someone that
Wasing on it you know and it's CU it's
such a shift and it's so it's so you
know it's so punk rock like to to say
like hierarchy where like you'll
create characters that you love and then
all of a sudden it shifts and you think
you know what the lead of this film is
and then you don't and I think it's
really ballsy and you pulled it off
really well thank you so much well
that's like I again haven't seen it but
that sounds a little bit like link
letters slacker where you know it it it
weaves but one of the things like and in
talk for you guys talk a little bit
about the fact that like I don't think
obviously everyone knows what the the
conventional narrative structure is of a
movie but that's just be like the way
it's been done it doesn't mean that's
the way you know like I I I really enjoy
experimental film making and what you're
doing with this I'm really excited to
see because it's not what I see all the
time so for actors can you talk
about is that one of the things or one
of the reasons you wanted to be a part
of a project like
this it just seemed really fun to dive
into
this wholly unique and juicy challenging
role for me for really just a few days
um I don't think about things in those
terms when I'm reading a script it's
really instinctual it's a gut feeling I
mean I could talk about you know the
fact that Jack is touching on issues
that I think we all need to be thinking
about and talking about and that are a
part of all of our lived experiences in
this moment and that he did it
beautifully and so skillfully and it's
deeply affecting but when I read the
script I'm just like oh this is
interesting really well written and
seems like a lot of fun this guy's
wonderful to talk to on the phone I have
a sense he's going to be wonderful on
set so really it's just like a do I want
to put myself in this world with these
people I'm not thinking about the
structure of the film I'm just like
ignorant about that um but having
now watched it I can really appreciate
that it
is doing things I've never seen done
before yet the overall effect is a
sincerely human
emotional grounded heartfelt beautiful
experience so that's all we're Ever
After however you can get there I think
is valid yeah and to kind of P piggyback
on that I think that if someone is going
to just write something specifically to
step out of the normaly of you know film
making you can read it you can see it it
smells it's like it's inauthentic you
know and so I think that even if a film
takes you on a journey of like breaking
you know uh convention when you're
reading it it shouldn't break you right
it'll it'll bring you in it won't you
won't realize that you're breaking
convention because it's going to be
lifting you or leading you towards
something that is very human and it'll
only be in the after effect of reading
it being like Oh there's all these
things happening and you were able to to
do all of these things for me when I
read a script that's sort of like and
now insert strange swirling edit and
like I just I feel like I get so it just
feels like I'm a computer like reading
it's just it doesn't feel right you know
you don't want it to be an intellectual
experience you want it to be an
emotional experience for me as an actor
reading a script even if it's super
impressive from sorry I don't know just
for me as my first time we were
saying I had no idea what was going to
happen and I was on this set and it was
like cut that there your wardrobe the
makeup let me touch you up do it again
do it from here do it from and then to
see this finished product that is
seamless it tells a story it's it just
goes through the stages of what it
should even my own scenes small ones
where he shot it five different ways and
just
it just Blends
and I it's it's so funny because I think
if if you haven't spent any time on a
movie set or a TV show whatever and
seeing how the sausage is made you would
not believe the way it is and and what
ends up on screen and how it the editing
how it all Cuts together I'm almost out
of time but I'm curious uh can you talk
a little bit about what were some of the
with with the budget and schedule you
had what were you most afraid of being
able to pull off and you know to bring
your the film film to life um I think I
mean I feel lucky in the sense that
obviously it being my first feature film
it was uh you know there was a huge
learning curve about a lot of you know
with a lot of stuff but I also was
coming into this movie probably having
spent more time on set than a lot of
firsttime filmmakers you know we just
talked about this that there is this
sort of you know first-time filmmaker
can mean so many different things you
know I've been shooting music videos and
commercials and you know spending a lot
of time on set and I come from a theater
background I feel like I had a lot of
stuff in the Arsenal and I do feel like
I was able to use some of my tricks I've
shot in every corner of La you know over
the last 10 years and so I think um
being able to use some of those tricks
to figure out where to really you know
juice the budget or or where to really
spend time in the schedule I felt very
lucky that I was able to kind of bring
some of that um energy to the table and
that you know and everyone involved
trusted me to sort of we we had to I had
to find new ways to work cuz it was
narrative but I also was able to use
some of my you know little tricks of the
trade that I had learned to to make
things smooth and make make it all kind
of shake out last thing for you guys and
we'll do it quick because I'm I'm really
I got to wrap but um for for everyone uh
what are you most looking forward to
audiences and it's a little generic I
apologize but what are you most looking
forward to audiences seeing with this
film I'll go back for just for me like
the Eternal shelf life of a film like I
love not knowing anything about a film
and being affected by something like
watching something in my 20s and
thinking it's this type of film and then
watching it again and seeing all of
these other things that I had never seen
from it to just be open I think any
audience that I would ever want to watch
any film that I've ever made to just be
curious and to stay open um because if
it's if you've made something that
you're really proud of the film will do
the work right the film's going to do
the work for you you can it can give you
questions it can give you answers it can
open up deep trauma it can heal deep
trauma I mean it's going to do the work
you just have to to come in sort of
curious to go where the film wants you
to uh for me I
guess to what you said about your movie
and what Jack said about his when you
first saw the first cut first thought is
I hope I'm not an impostor a I'm kidding
but kind we all have that thought I have
I for every day on set yeah also I just
being super vain I hope people think
it's funny and laugh and just have fun
cuz I had a lot of fun and I'm still
having a lot of fun I hope that just
carries and we feel that energy in the
theater um well I'm looking forward for
people to have this experience because
it is a really fun wild ride and and
what I think might at first seem like a
very cutting analysis and critique and
absurd and funny and terrifying ways of
this moment in our in time which I think
is terrifying in lots of ways move into
the deeper truth which is that we are
all connected by a need for one another
and a shared experience of both
suffering but also real love and a real
sense of the human um true desire for
communion you know we've been kind of
tricked into thinking we don't need that
um and that it can be we can be
redirected toward you know pills and let
the pharmaceutical industry profit off
of that or whatever technology but I I
the move into sort of the deeper truth
that it is all about human connection is
a very beautiful one that this film does
very elegantly I think I was going to
say I really have to wrap because I can
feel the energy of them telling me you
know what I mean but thanks for having
us I was just going to say I one more
time I want to give a huge huge thank
you to to film. uh which is the that you
can go to because seriously we wouldn't
be here without them and I'm really
grateful I'm really I really am looking
forward to seeing your movie and I
really hope uh it turns out you know
that everyone loves it tonight um thank
you so much for coming in thanks that's
really sweet we appreciate the
support